Io delle donne non sopporto che dicono che non si masturbano mai, ma andatevene a fa... - Che bucia...
- Ciao ragazzi bentornati ad una nuova puntata di Vita
Buttata, il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Maschi contro femmine"
Non è un pò sessista? - Un filino (Lavinia)
"Femmine contro maschi"
Che comunque è sessista - Mmm contro Mmm (Gianmarco)
- Il tema della puntata di oggi è "Mmm contro Mmm"
Un anno fa all'università di
Cambridge ha fatto lo studio più grande
che sia mai stato fatto su questo tipo
di tema, studiando 670 mila persone per
giungere alla conclusione, ossia che le
donne effettivamente tendono ad avere un
cervello più empatico e gli uomini un
cervello più sistematico, dicendo che
effettivamente ci sono delle differenze
Non sono al cento per cento d'accordo, a
livello proprio di esperienza che io ho
su queste grandi differenze fra uomini e
donne
ma per farci una risata abbiamo comunque
chiesto di farci sapere quali sono
quelle cose che vi danno fastidio delle
altre persone, ed è per questo anche che
ho deciso di invitare all'interno degli
studios de casa mia non una ma due
persone che tutti quanti dicono essere
le vere star di questo canale
Ho accettato di fare un passo indietro ed è
per questo che vi presento oggi per la
prima volta una co-conduzione tra mio
fratello Enrico e mia cugina Lavinia
- Prego prego. Spostati!
- Come sei inquietante qua dietro (*verso gufo*)
- Non vi dovete sentire osservati, loro
dovranno ascoltare i commenti che
verranno fatti dalle persone e decidere,
diciamo quale tesi sostenere. Abbiamo
diciamo se sosterrete gli uomini il baffo - Il mustacchio     - Che per essere dunque
paritari anche le donne hanno i baffi - Ma me li levo con quello che mi costa - Anche gli uomini hanno le labbra
- Partiamo ad ascoltare? - Assolutamente si - Com'è che si chiama? (Gu) - Uomini (Gianmarco) - Ajajajaj
- Per praticità di salvataggio (Gianmarco) - Ma uomini nel senso di... - Donne (Gu) - Ciao ragazzi sono sempre
qui con loro - Io non voglio stare senza di te
- Come funziona questo attrezzo? - Ma come funziona questa puntata? Ma dove siamo?
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, di cose che odio di altre donne ne ho veramente tante, primo fra tutti
quello del "Ma lui non abbassa mai la
tavoletta del cesso quando va in bagno"
Abbassala te scusa, lui la deve alzà l'abbassi te. Equa distribuzione dei compiti no?
Equa distribuzione degli sforzi in
casa. O ancora il classico "Se non mi
offre lui la cena allora io non gliela
do". Scusa che stai a vende la passera?
Figlia mia il femminismo esiste, fatti
valere, responsabilizzati ed equalizzati - Brava!
- Brava, ma mi è piaciuta proprio. Brava, guarda mi alliscio proprio il mustacchio
- Non sopporto chi manda il c***o in chat
perché svilisce tutto il genere maschile
ma soprattutto fa fare una brutta figura
a chi non lo fa. Quando scrivete a
qualcuno usate la testa non la testa del c***o
- Ma tu sei un genio! Si può fare un pacchettino e mandargli una medaglia?
- Senti ridammi questo coso - Devo dire una cosa - Tu sei uno che lo manda, hai la
faccia di uno che lo manda - Nooo
C'è da dire che non c'è nulla di male nell'inviare... un c***o o una passera in una chat
- Diciamo che a mio
avviso non è proprio il più graditissimo
dei presenti, così a caldo - Ma no così su due piedi - Ma su due p**i volevi dire? - ... Ciao cara "Bom"
E' quello si brutto - Quello si, quello si - Io invece adesso devo
fare quelli che lo difendono il c***o in chat "Hey ciao pupa"
- Allora innanzitutto ciao Gu e ciao ospite - Ciao caro        - Allora scusa ho un po' di mal di gola - Tranquillo
- A me da fastidio una cosa, sia degli uomini che delle donne, ovvero sono i luoghi comuni
Ho una collega che sfrutta tantissimo
"Eh no sai perché noi donne" No! Non è voi donne, sei te che sei una ritardata - L'ha toccata pianissimo
- O tipo  un mio amico "No perché sai a noi il ca ..." No! Ti piace la f**a, va bene, c'è a chi piace il c***o
Ed è quello il bello anche. E niente sono un po' pazzo, quindi ciao - Ha detto una cosa molto saggia
- Scorporiamo - Ma che ti serve? - La penna... Ha detto che non ti puoi nascondere dietro un'etichetta per
dire una cosa che in realtà è una tua
caratteristica - Anche io detesto le
generalizzazioni, detesto i luoghi comuni
a sfondo sessuale/sessista, ma
ancor di più sinceramente detesto le persone che
respirano e con una temperatura corporea al di sopra dei 30 gradi centigradi - Tu sei una che ci fa caso
tipo se ti offrono la cena, se ti aprono
la porta (Gu) - Allora quando ero giovane
in realtà ci facevo molto caso,
soprattutto perché comunque veniamo da
una famiglia in cui fortunatamente gli
uomini sono tutti molto molto molto
galante - E diciamolo - Questo va detto
- Poi sono dei calfini messi all'impiedi
- Vuoi dare la definizione di calfino (Gianmarco)
- Ah non sapete cos'è un calfino. Enrico a breve vi spiegherà cosa sia un calfino - Ma non lo so neanche io
- Cioè... - Perchè un calfino. So che è un
incrocio tra un cavallo - Che dorme all'impiedi - ...E un delfino - ...Che dorme nuotando - E' un dormiente
E' un...guarda non so come dirtelo di più, un autentico calfino - Tipo i materassi no?
Adesso invece ho capito che nonostante
secondo me la galanteria sia veramente
alla base di ogni tipologia di rapporto,
adesso ho imparato che si fa quello che
si può - Tu Enrico invece? (Gu) - Io offro sempre tutto       - Oh tipico dei calfini - Esatto
Sono dei mammiferi i calfini - A me Enrico non m'ha offerto manco una gomma
Ciao Gu e ciao anche a te ospite e ciao Enrico, quello che non sopporto delle donne è che spesso e volentieri
sono attratte da un uomo e magari hanno
anche il coraggio di approcciarlo però
dicono sempre quella stramaledetta frase
che io odio "Tu sei l'uomo, devi fare il
primo passo". In una società così evoluta
come dovrebbe essere oggi nel 2019
perché si pensa ancora che sia l'uomo
sempre a dover fare il primo passo?
Se si vuole l'uguaglianza tra i sessi si deve volere in tutto - In realtà la donna fa
credere all'uomo di fare il primo passo - Come sei saggio - Perché è  la donna  la
cacciatrice e l'uomo abbocca sempre
all'amo - Il calfino è diventato saggisimo
- Pensa se quella m fosse stata una n (Gu) - Che cosa?
- Non si può fare una puntata senza Willwoosh, mi sta venendo... - Un'ansia
Questi so due - No l'ultimo è 0,2 secondi, sarà tipo "Ciao" - Ciao - Eh....Ciao - Ma quindi già l'hai sentito tu
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, volevo dire che non è che c'è qualcosa che non
sopporto degli uomini in genere, io non sopporto le
mamme degli uomini, servi li e li
trattano come se fossero dei principini
e così prima che maturano devono passare
50 anni se va bene - Io non ce l'ho per
niente con i mammini, non ho avuto alcuna
esperienza - Il tuo astio non esiste (Gu) - Assolutamente no - La critica è rivolta al genitore
non al figlio - Nono non ci abbiamo capito niente, questi figli sono pericolosissimi!
Stai lontana da loro! A meno che non siano, non vorrei cadere nel solito clichè
- Ma hai imbrattato di rossetto pure quest'altro lato?        - Sempre a sgridarmi, sempre a reprimere la mia indole
- Maschilista! (Gu) - Maschilista!
- Se proprio devo parlare di quello che mi dà fastidio
dell'altro sesso, beh il fatto che
quando le chiedi come sta ti dice "bene"
e intanto brandisce un machete
insanguinato dietro la schiena che
nasconde molto bene anche se tu in realtà
un po' vedi questa punta insanguinata che è
lì lì per trafiggerti ....cavolo - ... E' stato ammazzato... Dietro c'era la ragazza proprio così
- Cor machete. Non so tu chi frequenti tesoro carissimo ma nessuna donna di dirà "bene", ti diremo "niente"
- Una cosa che non sopporto delle
donne, perché parlate la mattina? La mattina
bisogna dormire, bisogna odiare il
prossimo - Bravo - Mattina pomeriggio e sera
bisogna dormire - Io conosco un sacco di uomini che sono super iperattivi  la mattina - E logorroici
- E di donne che si sono
completamente morte - Io non voglio
comunicare con nessuno
personalmente e parlo in qualità di
donna in questo momento - Io non voglio
comunicare con nessuno, ho i baffi, ho i baffi
- Sei il mio partner ideale allora. Ma vieni
a covare il tuo odio con noi
Non ti agitare. Intanto lo vedi che scorrazza
con la sua sedia dietro - Avvolto tra i cavi...
La mattina uno se deve sta zitto
- Assolutamente - Che vuol dire la mattina uno deve stare zitto? Fino a che orario? Cioè fino alle 18?
Dipende a che ora ti alzi - 14 30 direi, può essere un buon orario - Ma tipo se ti
alzi e sei già... - Attivo, felice, vedi il mondo
meraviglioso, tienitelo per te
- Non importa quanti messaggi tu possa
mandare ad un ragazzo, lui risponderà
sempre e solo all'ultimo - E soprattutto, a
fronte del tuo panegirico, risponderà
sempre e solo... ok - Io qui purtroppo non posso dire niente perché è così
- Io non sopporto quando la gente mi piange in faccia, soprattutto quando sono uomini ma
- Ma io lo trovo una cosa così carina invece - Ma ragazzi
non c'e niente di più bello di una
persona che piange in generale, che
dimostra di essere umana
Le riviste le compri per la copertina
ma le butti dopo un giorno. Cioè se le vuoi
prendere per tutta la vita invece le
persone devi un attimo andare oltre la
prima pagina. Sbom me ne rivado, ciao - Non solo ma non hai
paura dei tuoi sentimenti, cioè noi
viviamo dentro sta società in cui è tutto
filtrato, tutto instagrammato, io adoro
invece le persone ... veraci
C'ho una cosa nell'occhio - Oh Enrico! - Non sopporto quegli uomini che dicono che le
donne siano impedite a guidare. Ma chi ve l'ha detto?      - Maledetti! - Cioè questa cosa mi fa venire la testa
contro il muro ok? - E se sei in macchina si - Ciao Gu ciao ospite, una cosa
che non sopporto delle donne, in
particolar modo della mia ragazza, essere
sempre in ritardo. Quando chiedendole "Amore a che
punto sei?" mi dice "Sono pronta" e me
e me lo dice mentre corre tutta sudata in
intimo per casa e il problema è che io sono lì
- Rigà sapete chi è la persona più ritardatari a del
mondo? Gabriele e Luigi, sono comunque
due uomini. Cioè i ratardatari saranno sempre
ritardatari , uomini o donne che siano
- Beh è di famiglia essere in ritardo comunque - Io impazzisco però coi ritardi , cioè io
quando io sono in ritardo -Guarda tu stai  sempre in ritardo eh - Ma io impazzisco
- Cioè impazzisci al pensiero che non fai il ritardo giusto?
- Stai prendendo troppe... - "Fuori dal mio canale"! - Troppe libertà - Comunque facci finire il video Guglielmo
- Sempre queste intrusioni - Ritardatario
- Questo canale non è un albergo va bene?
- Andate avanti!
Fate ridere il pubblico - Ciao Guglielmo e ciao ospite, spero sia Martina Pinto
vabbè se non è Martina Pinto fa niente
- Manco a trattacce così però! Se vuoi ti mettiamo la faccia di Martina Pinto - Per favore me lo puoi fare?
- Io voglio essere Martina - Le cose che
non sopporto degli uomini o meglio che non
capisco è quando gli uomini si
abbracciano e dopo che sono stretti in
un abbraccio si danno anche delle pacche
sulle spalle, forti. Perché hanno il
bisogno di farsi male anche quando si
abbracciano, io non lo capisco - Perché così
non mostrano di essere troppo dolci (Gu )  - Forse perché sono dei vigorosi rugbisti
nessuno di noi c'ha pensato? E' placcaggio, non solo pacche sulla spalla, ho studiato le regole
- Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video, spero che questo
esperimento vi sia piaciuto e soprattutto
vi ringrazio per i vostri commenti, sono
contento, contentissimo di avere persone
che parlano come esseri del presente e del
2019. Temevo che potessimo toccare
veramente - Il fondo - ...Il fondo e invece
questo fondo non è stato toccato
- Perché siamo andati ancora più sotto - Si - Abbiamo surfato alla
grande questa onda - In profondità
- Abbiamo mostrato qual è il futuro, abbiamo mostrato
qual il presente e questa cosa mi riempie
di orgoglio, infatti c' ho un sorriso da qui a qui
come lo Stregatto. Detto ciò
ringrazio Enrico, ringrazio Lavinia, per
la loro partecipazione - E' sessita se ringrazi prima Enrico - Giusto, quindi non lo ringraziamo proprio
- Ringrazia prima Lavinia, io non  mi offendo...anzi non mi ringraziare... "Non ringrazio nessuno"
- Non ringrazio nessuno per aver preso parte a questo video. Fatemi sapere qua sotto se siete d'accordo con
quello che avete sentito, se siete
d'accordo con i grandi studi di
Cambridge ma soprattutto fatemi sapere
quali sono le vostre esperienze. Come
sempre vi invito a iscrivervi, ad attivare la
campanellina delle notifiche qua sotto
per non perdervi i prossimi video. Detto
ciò ci vediamo il prossimo giovedì
sempre alle 14 con un nuovo Vita Buttata. Ciao - Ciao mamma sono sul tubo
- Vabbè ma la zia non la salutate? Ciao zia - Ciao zia - Ciao mamma
- Rugbisti